e
so uh good morning everyone uh and I
should oh sorry sorry good morning
everyone and I should say for the for
the people on on the committee here this
is actually my second uh time uh meeting
this group uh because I also serve as a
member of the judicial selection
commission and we uh uh Lynn chalette
and my who's also a member of the
commission and myself met with them um
on Monday so uh welcome again this is
the house Judiciary Committee um uh
these are a really delightful uh group
of visitors and I'm going to ask them if
they if you uh could please introduce
yourself and then we will introduce
ourselves I encourage them to use a yes
oh sure that's fine yeah great good
morning uh my name is Andre Fu I'm from
Romania uh from the ministry of Justice
uh there I'm head of the crime
prevention department meaning that uh we
handle the anti-corruption policy and
the anti-organized crime policy um and
also the social reintegration of
offenders um and thank you very much for
having us here um looking forward to the
discussions today thank
you good morning everyone my name is
sava Petro I come from sopia Bulgaria
I've been working is a chief expert at
the legal Affairs Committee of the
National Assembly of the Republic of
Bulgaria for 9 years already uh my M my
main job uh requirements include uh
preparing draft legislative act
providing uh legal advises carrying out
analysis uh legislative studies uh uh
making uh comparative uh of the European
legislation and that's maybe the most
great thank you
welcome good morning everyone I'm so
excited to be here I'm from Spain my
name is hin I'm judge in Spain the
national high court it's a court that
has jurisdiction in all the country in
the criminal field and we hold cases
like terrorism or crime organization
ation drug
trafficking corruption the highest
crimes that we have in Spain thank you
very much and I hope to learn a lot of
you great well welcome again thank
you uh good morning everyone uh thanks
for your time my name is Cynthia wo I'm
from wenos Iris Argentina I work in
customs just in the investigation of
criminal cases connected to um uh
weapons drugs and any other things
Contraband cause cases and fraud cases
and I work with federal agencies and
federal Justice thank you thanks for
coming good morning um my name is Kum I
am from The Gambia and I serve as a
legal researcher of for the Supreme
Court of The Gambia which is responsible
for dealing with all constitutional
issues in Gambia and also receives
appeal from the court of appeal so
specifically I am a legal researcher for
the Chief Justice and also his personal
assistant I am glad to be here and to
meet all of you well we're glad you're
here also thank you thank
you good morning everyone I'm Surin from
Sri Lanka uh I'm a practicing lawyer uh
human rights lawyer uh I mainly work on
cases related to torture uh sexual
violence against women uh political
prisoners cases under terrorism act um
yeah so thank you very much to yeah
thank
you good morning my name is anger Tumi I
am a judge at the special court of
appeals for corruption and organ
organized crime in Albania uh my court
deals uh with cases regarding corruption
organized crime offenses in public
procurement and uh also adjudicating the
most senior officials in my country like
the Prime Minister the president of the
Republic the ministers the Parliamentary
members and the Mayors I'm also a
part-time lecturer at the school of uh
of magistrate thank you for your time
and it's a good opportunity for me being
here thank you thank you what school
school of magistrates it's a school
which prepares the Jud judges and
prosecutors it's mandatory thank you
thank
you good morning I'm Maria from Slovak
Republic former Czechoslovakia I work as
a director of international Affairs for
the Constitutional Court of the Slovak
Republic which is basically the same
institution as your Supreme Court of the
United States and I'm also Vice
Chancellor of the Court thank you great
thank you for
coming good morning my name is Barak
brusle I'm International cooperation
prosecutor from the state of Kuwait and
I'm honored to be here with you all
thank you thank
you good morning to everyone my name is
ARA I come from Kosovo I work as a judge
in the commercial Court of Kosovo which
is a special court that has a
jurisdiction within the whole territory
of
Kosovo thank
you you don't know me my name is Anise
and I'm with the world affairs Council
of New Hampshire which is a local
organizing company that works in the
state to administer What's called the
international visitor leadership program
this program is funded through the
Department of State has been around
since 1940 brings up and cominging
leaders to the US on a 3-week journey
based on a professional Pro this group
is in the country on a rule of law group
they will visit up
to they've done DC New Hampshire I have
half of the group the other half is we
Minneapolis then they'll be in Reno
Nevada and then San Francisco for their
final destination throughout the whole
journey they will be meeting with
professionals B around this theme and
topic they will also have an opportunity
to do what's called home Hospitality
which is where an individual like any of
you can invite a few of them into your
home have conversations and dinner and
this is the most important part because
it's helping to build a better
perception of so I'd like to say thank
you all for having us here and coming
today and I hope that we have some
fruitful
conversation well again well welcome um
as I mentioned just some people may have
uh on the committee may have arrived
later uh a little late I this is my
second opportunity to meet with this
group because uh I met with them on
Monday uh in my role as a member of the
judicial selection commission but again
I want to welcome you um I'm I'm this is
the Judiciary Committee of the House of
Representatives I I serve as chair uh to
my right is representative Scott Wallace
who is the vice chair and to his right
is representative uh Margie Smith who is
the ranking member of the I'm a
republican as is Mr Wallace
representative Smith is the ranking
member of the Democrats we are equally
divided on this committee there are 10
Republicans and 10 Democrats um and uh
with that I'm going to um ask first uh
representative Wallace and then
representative Smith if you would
introduce yourself and then I would
propose to kind of go around the
room good morning everyone thank you for
making the journey here uh my name is
representative Scott Wallace I represent
the town of Danville Rockingham County 8
uh I also am the uh chairman of the
Rockingham County Sheriff's Office and I
sit on the special committee on housing
as well again thank you for uh coming to
to see how we operate up here in state
of New Hampshire and uh it's great to
have you all
here I'm Marjorie Smith from Durham and
six of you know that CU you were at my
house for dinner on Sunday evening and
we had I I had a terrific time I hope
you did too
this is something that I have done for
many years um of
having groups like yours come for dinner
and I have never had a bad evening it's
wonderful fun to talk very freely and
openly about your countries and about
this country and um I can't think of a
better way to spend some time and I'm
just delighted to have you all here
today welcome to New Hampshire I hope
you have a great trip while you're here
and enjoy your stay my name is Louise
Andress I come from Salsbury a little
town north of here I represent Marat
County District 5 five small towns and
Nova Danbury Hill Salsbury and Webster
this is my second term as a House member
on my second term being on the Judiciary
Committee I enjoy enjoy law I'm not a
lawyer I am a retired office manager but
I enjoy law and I have enjoyed my time
on the Judiciary Committee it's a great
committee we all get along well we don't
always agree but we get along well and
we have a resolution to all our bills
thank you and have a good
stay good morning thanks for being here
in the gentleman from Spain I just
booked a trip can I have your card in
case I get in trouble while I'm there
invite my name is Christine Perez I am
from London der New Hampshire um that is
Rockingham district 16 this is my first
year well second year first term as
being a rep I'm a retired intensive care
nurse so Judiciary was very foreign to
me I have learned a lot um I once in a
while I'll have to say would you please
talk in real language and not legales so
I understand um but it's been a great
opportunity and a great opportunity to
have you all here thank you for being
here thank
you good morning my name is Mark page I
represent the town of exitor which is on
New Hampshire Sea Coast if you look at a
map of New Hampshire we have a sliver of
that borders the Atlantic Ocean and I'm
almost there we exitor is the home of
Philips exitor Academy which is a pretty
prestigious independent school and many
other things so um hopefully you can
come down and and see us and say hello
on your short trip and welcome to New
Hampshire thanks for
coming and I'm an attorney
yes welcome to all of you my name is Zoe
Manos I'm from stratum which is down
near the Sea Coast I actually adjoin
Mark toown uh I'm an attorney I'm a
freshman so this is my first year in the
house second year but first term in the
house um I practice family law and I
love this committee we have we we are
very collegial we have different points
of view um but we all get along and we
hash out issues and I have found that
the process in the house is very very
Democratic with a small D so all bills
um that are introduced get a hearing in
whatever committee is relevant and then
they all get a vote in the committee and
then they all go to the floor and they
all get a a vote on the floor so it's
different from our federal system where
uh
Congress can the Speaker of the House
can control What legislation goes to the
floor here it's very it's very open and
it's very Democratic and I really enjoy
that process thank
you uh good morning my name is Richard
trip uh I'm from dairy which is uh the
home of uh Alan Shepard the first person
in
space uh
I met you earlier and talked with you uh
uh this is my third term uh first one on
uh Judiciary I spent the my other two
terms on uh Municipal and county law uh
people ask me uh why why I go up why I
go to the uh the state house and I says
well it's uh mostly to make sure that uh
uh the state keeps their nose out of the
the town's business you know uh we're a
very independent bunch in uh New
Hampshire and uh we like to control our
own lives you know uh I uh thank you for
coming you know today I hope you learn
something from our discussions and uh
and have a good time in Reno any of you
gamblers thank
you hi welcome uh my name is Ben Ming
I'm a lawyer I'm a first term State
represent ative for the town of Hollis
which is on the Massachusetts New
Hampshire border and um this is actually
my first year on Judiciary in the prior
year I I sat on fishing game and um
welcome to New Hampshire thank
you good morning good morning and
welcome uh my name is Mike wette I'm a
first term legislator I represent Coos
District 3 I'm the representative that
lives the furthest away from the State
House in the state I'm filling in today
in judiciary I'm very happy and proud to
be here and my regular assignment I'm on
the fishing game Committee in for the
state thank
you yeah hi welcome everyone um my name
is uh representative Eric tur uh
representative town uh of Brentwood also
over by the Sea Coast to join
representative paiges town and fairly
close to representative Manos um all of
our population a lot of it is
concentrated in that corner of our state
so so there's a lot of us from from that
neck and woods um it's great to have
folks from you know sort of Bey beyond
the borders of our of Our Little World
here to talk about um things that that
sometimes were usually very narrow
focused uh my career has been in um uh
Public Health um policy Consulting
around access to care um for underserved
groups um I work for a company called
JSI that does work here in the United
States and a lot of work um in in the
rest of the world um so it's nice to
nice to have you all here thanks for
coming good morning thank you all for
coming today and um thank you for coming
to visit New Hampshire really I think
it's wonderful and such a great
opportunity for us to learn more about
your backgrounds um today uh my name is
Shelley dine and I this is my first term
on the Judiciary Committee my first term
as a legislator I did not set out at all
to become this it just kind of happened
all in one one swoops one stroke of of
uh people asking they needed somebody to
come up and represent and um I I I
stepped up and and um it has been a
great experience um not having any
really law background but uh working
along with this group the leadership has
been wonderful especially for somebody
new to this kind of
process and um I can't I can't say
enough we've really been very I think
this group has been very blessed to be
able to work together and um I represent
nashwa too um the we had 27 Democrats
come from one town so it was a big um a
big deal for that town and we're right
on the in case you're wondering we're
right on the the Massachusetts border
south of here so thanks
um it's an honor to meet you all my name
is Janine ner I'm the House Majority
Whip and serving my 14th year in the
house I started out on state and federal
relations and Veterans Affairs I also
did time in this committee at Judiciary
um a couple of terms
um what else is there to say um I'm
originally from California so not the
Bay Area I have a sister there there so
so when you get to San Francisco I hope
you get a chance to tour alcatrez Island
it's very interesting and sometimes they
have former inmates there so I met a
retired bank robber very nice
man he's retired as a
bank the pension is a little bit tricky
but
uh require minimum
distribution welcome um I my name's uh
Judy lonza and this is my first term I'm
a actual uh labor and delivery nurse um
I work at a local hospital um in
Manchester and and um I represent
Goffstown uh District 29 and um and like
I said being this first term I'm not I
wasn't um acquainted with a lot of law
uh but at the same time I've learned a
lot and and like everybody has said we
uh all get along really well and we all
learn a lot from each other as well and
um I want to also say out to Spain I've
been many times to Spain I have friends
there in Madrid and um love love love
love Spain so um like I said hope to get
back sometime soon thank
you good morning and welcome my name is
representative Charlotte D Lorenzo and
I'm from New Market New Hampshire which
is also on the Sea Coast in Rockingham
County um we're on the Sea Coast and we
have a river that runs through town so
it's a really wonderful Scenic town of
about U maybe n 9,000 people I'm in my
fourth term in the house um I selected
Judiciary because I have a background in
housing management and in legal studies
um and so I've had the opportunity to
work on a lot of bills that had to do
with my career my 35 year career as a
housing manager so the type of housing
that I managed I think in Europe it's
called social housing um it's affordable
housing low income moderate income um
and it's it's it's been a blast and I I
love serving on this committee I like
the people that I work with um every one
of them is different and everyone has
different skills different attributes
and um it's been a really great blend so
thank you for
coming thank you oh well I think we have
someone just yes hi if you yes if you
would just introduce your this is a
group from the world affairs Council um
and they have they're really from all
over the world um and maybe if you would
wouldn't mind just introducing
yourself my name is representative
Christine cybert um I'm from Manchester
um Ward one in Manchester District 21
and I appreciate um everybody being here
today I'm looking forward to hearing
from you thank you thank you so what I'd
like to do maybe just just very briefly
because I I want to make sure that the
the main thing we do is answer your
questions and talk about things that you
are interested in um uh and I know
you've already heard from me on Monday
so I'm going to let my colleagues do
most of the talking for us but just very
briefly uh to give you just a little bit
of background as representative Manos
pointed out um this is we are a somewhat
unique
um legislative body our government uh in
New Hampshire is is is a little bit
different so to speak than the than the
typical government around the country
and so just as an example our governor
is elected for only two years um I think
Vermont does no Vermont changed didn't
they they are they now are four but we
are one of the few States we may be the
only state but if but there might be one
or two other states that elect their
governor for only two years most States
it's four years um in addition to
that the go the governor is the head of
the executive branch of the government
but most of the leader most of the heads
of agencies that are under the executive
branch of the government have the heads
of those agencies are appointed for
terms of four or five years um so
you know that the governor doesn't the
governor doesn't have the same kind of
authority over the executive branch of
our government that the president of the
United States has over the executive
branch of the federal government our
legislature as you as you may or may not
have heard we have 400 members of the of
This House of Representatives in a state
of about a million3 million 300,000
population so every one of us represents
about 3,800 3600 something like that
people so um we you know we are pretty
close so to speak to the to the people
now we have a pretty small Senate we
have there are 24 uh
Senators um uh which is you know that's
a big difference between the size of the
house in the size of the Senate uh and
we have the you we have the same system
of how laws are enacted as the federal
government in the sense that in order
for a for a uh law to be enacted it has
to be passed by both houses of the
legislature and then signed by the
governor or if the governor vetos it
then it has to be over the veto has to
be overridden by a two-thirds vote of
both houses so that's kind of similar to
the to the um federal government but um
as representative man has pointed out we
uh one big difference in our system is
that every bill that is that is proposed
by a
representative is assigned to a
committee and it gets a hearing even if
and you know candidly some bills are you
know really out there you know it's uh
you you you look at it and you say what
how but it gets a hearing
and it goes to the and even if it's you
know if the committee recommends against
it even if the committee recommends
unanimously against it it still goes to
the floor for a vote and you know if
there's a representative who wants to
you know make a a fight on the floor to
try to get the the body to pass it uh
they can do that so that um uh that
really is does make it a very sort of
democratic uh uh uh process um with that
I'm going to um I'm going to sort of
open it to you for do you have questions
we'd love to answer your questions and
uh and then if if my colleagues have
other things that they think are
important to talk about I'm I as I say
I'm you should be hearing from we want
to hear from you and from them as
opposed to from me thank you excuse me
you forgot to mention that we make a
$100 a year oh that's in Very Yes we get
a the for for the work we put in we are
paid $100 a
year which we which we we pay taxes on
so basically this is kind of volunteer
service um which you know there are some
good parts to that there really are um
on the other hand it tends to mean that
there are a lot of people like myself
who are retired and who have the time or
who are business people and have the
time
um which which can tend to skew you know
how uh uh who the people are that serve
as Representatives um that that that
that that's unquestionably true I think
um so what can what what do you have for
questions for
us have one question
which
which are the most uh challenging
current bills nowadays in your
community I would have to say
that the general category of challenging
bills
this term and many terms is
education that is who
pays for for Education where the money
comes from and where the money
goes um there is a a movement
nationally um that is very real here in
New
Hampshire to um
take money that was traditionally
focused in the public
schools and understand that the schools
are
controlled by the cities and
towns and mo much of the money comes
from the cities and towns but the money
that the state puts in is very
important um the movement that is very
popular across the country now with not
with everyone but with some people is to
take that public
money and rechannel it not to the public
schools but to other entities whether
traditional schools or not that um of
parent might want to use to educate
their children and so they lots of
related issues with that the issues
related to
curriculum although it you know when
they say it's not the money it always
comes down to money um but you know
there are other issues and I think
that's
probably in many ways affects us across
many of our committees it's not the only
issue um and the issue that this
particular committee has been working on
with a great deal of commitment trying
to find the right way would I I say come
into the general category of
transparency and
accountability um and uh and that
affects as you can well imagine every
aspect of government and significant um
aspects in the private sector so those
be the the two areas I would think
mention most I'm sure other people have
different ideas Mr chairman
oh I'm sorry repes oh thank you um I
wanted to agree that I think uh that the
education Freedom accounts are probably
the most contentious issue this term um
there have been others in the past and
we have a different perspective so I
wanted that's why I asked to speak
because I the conservative side and um
the way we see it is all right the
average cost for per student in New
Hampshire is $220,000 a year per
student uh the less students in the
school means less taxpayers money
spending on us so if it cost $20,000 to
to educate one child if they're using
the education Freedom accounts it's
$5,000 so there's $155,000 savings so
it's just a matter of of your
perspective and
um I I support the efas you know can can
I just ask you ask could could some of
you one or more of you I mean I wonder
if you could just tell us one of the
things that is happening in New
Hampshire and I think in many other
states in the United States is that our
student population is
dropping in other words we've we've had
like a 15 or 20% maybe it's even more
than that decline in our in the number
of students that attend school in New
Hampshire over say the last 15 years or
so is that is that kind of trend true in
your countries
also I'm seeing sounds like it
isn't
right you're the number of schoolage
children has that is that going
up that's what I would have thought and
I think that's true in other countries
too is it true in The Gambia yeah
um what about
Albania and what's happening in Kosovo
where you you have
a dramatic change in population
age on that same subject
um I was put here by parents um during
covid um a a lot of parents were very
upset about what was going on in our
schools as far as their children being
Master you know um things going on so I
I'm a retired nurse I had no intentions
of being a state representative but
because I spoke at school meetings
parents put me here and I think one of
the things that our freedom accounts
allow is um one one shop does not make
it for everybody one it's some kids just
you may live in a town but that
particular School is not what you may
need and does not offer what you may
need as an individual and I think that
is one of the biggest driving SP forces
and um to have children be available to
go to other schools for example if you
have a school that is not offering
anything in the trades at all then
perhaps it is better for them to be able
to utilize um State money we also have a
lot of of charter schools in this state
and they're going up like crazy and they
get they're public but they get a very
limited amount of money so I happen to
have been at a fundraiser for one on
Saturday night so there's a lot of
Parental involvement so there's a lot
more to it than it's a it's a lot of
things so representative trip and then
representative page the uh I can't
remember who who said that uh the
schools are controlled by the uh the
towns I I think that's something of a
misnomer because uh as is always happens
we have uh we have well in in uh in New
Hampshire we have school boards uh
people who are locally elected to uh uh
oversee the schools but uh for the most
part we have uh administrators
bureaucrats who actually run the schools
and uh uh there's there's some
discussion about how the schools are
being run you know by uh as
representative Perez said that uh there
are parents that uh are not uh in
agreement with the how the schools are
being run so so that's that's something
of a uh a discussion that's going on in
the state right now uh you know the uh
the school boards they have uh
three-year terms and uh their basic
responsibility is is to
uh hire the superintendent which is the
the highest uh position in the schools
and to set policies you know so
uh some of the policies that they set
are not
uh agreed to by the parents and the the
residents in the town so like like most
places there's a as I said some heated
discussion that goes
on
I hi I have a question for you all um
and I'll just reflect on how the
governance structure of public education
is in the United States we have this
weird mix of every state has a duty to
provide a free education to every
student and some have said that's kind
of a crown jewel of of America is that
we do that all take all cers um but at
the same time the federal government
funds about 10% of a bud so we have this
weird mix and the local towns that we
cities that we represent raise property
taxes to fund that model and the state
has other means to do that so there's
all these sort of mix of governmental uh
levels and I'm just curious who's in
charge uh is it is it is it that
complicated and and messy or is there
who's in charge of of education for a
public if if there is such thing um in
your place in wherever s countries that
you're coming com from
yeah got to start from some place yeah
um in my country I come from
Romania uh in my country it's a mix of
public and private
schools uh as far as public schools are
concerned then again you have a mix of
uh the uh state run schools and local
schools most of the schools are owned by
the local government so uh even though
they get budgetary allowances from the
national budget the way they administer
the funds it's up to the local community
and up to the local government um so uh
from this point of view it can be a bit
challenging because the overseeing power
of the uh of the national Ministry of
Education uh is not that is not enough
to make sure that the funds are spent in
a way that that would comply with the
national policy on education because the
schools have a a very large Mandate of
of uh dealing with their own funds and
the local government has again a lot of
leeway uh on the way they spend their
their budget but most of it comes from
the state budget from the national
budget could I ask a question um how are
your
judges selected are they elected are
they
appointed
um you again yeah because in this case
now this is a question that gets an
easier answer from the point of view of
European States because we have to apply
Council of Europe standards uh so more
or less in Europe you you're going to
have the same system uh everywhere
meaning that you get a Judicial Council
which it may vary by name from country
to country but nevertheless you get
something which is called the judicial
Council usually composed mostly of
Judges there there can be uh uh members
which are not part of the Judiciary but
usually they are in minority as compared
to judges one of the principles we have
uh stemming from the Council of Europe
conventions uh is that the Judiciary
body should self-regulate as much as
possible uh meaning also that they're in
charge of their own career for judges
and prosecutors so you're going to have
this body usually um making appointments
for judges and then it goes to the head
of state but this is usually just a
formality
uh usually it's the head of state that
uh signs the official document
appointing a judge to his or her
position but again usually uh in Romania
certainly that is the case the president
of the country cannot refuse a
nomination coming from judicial
Council um because one of the principles
that we have again stemming from the
Council of Europe conventions is to
limit as much as possible the
involvement of the executive power in
the running of the Judiciary
that's in short so you must be amused to
watch us um with in terms of our United
States Supreme Court appointments you
don't have to comment I'm just you know
I know you're going to be polite about
that um are there terms uh or are or
judges um selected for Life For Life
most of the time and is there um uh a
senior age cut off that's a a very a
very delicate subject because sitting at
this table is someone who had to leave
the court that he loved um when he
reached 70 and we now are trying to um
uh amend the Constitution to raise that
to
75 in his honor so what
um what uh is there an age cut off that
depends um it could be 60 65 70 depends
on the country
y The Gambia The
Gambia okay so um our retirement age for
judges is 75 in The Gambia um it it was
not over 75 it was 65 so um there was a
constitutional amendment to change the
age from 65 to 75 that is the mandatory
retirement but they still have the
option to retire at the age of 65 so I
just wanted talk about like the
selection process for judges in my
country we have the Judicial Service
Commission that is that comprises the
Chief Justice uh the whole process is
judiciary LED so it has nothing to do
with the executive or the legislature so
the the the chairperson of the
commission is the Chief Justice and then
there is another judge of the Supreme
Court and then there is a nomination
from the executive and the legislature
and then a senior member of the bar and
another lay person it could be a retired
civil servant or any other person so
that is how judges are selected and
those people would recommend would have
a pool of people and then um select a
suitable person for the position of a
judge and then send the name to the
president so as in other countries in
Europe the president would just sign the
appointment so the
President appoints under the
recommendation of the Judicial Service
Commission so it's very strange that
when we come here the process is
completely different and um in my
country it's solely Judiciary L um
process
and it's interesting do you have any
questions yeah you know what I wonder if
this is really a question I've just
asked to EV to to all of you it's from
from what the discussion we had on
Monday it it it sounds like at least in
many of your countries that there is a
a closer for for lack of a better term a
closer relationship
between the prosecutorial authorities
and the court than is true than is true
here in other words I if I understood
correctly many um in in some of your
countries I think there is
a the training is sort of the same for
both is that true no for that is the
civil law system there is that closer
relationship in the civil law system
but in my country it's a common law
country so there is a complete
separation between the prosecution and
the Judiciary so in my country the
prosecution is under the executive which
is the we have the Attorney General we
don't have we have the attorney general
who occupies both position of Minister
of Justice and also attorney general so
he is under the executive he or she is
under the executive so um the Judiciary
is completely different it's this
another arm of government and the
executive is under the Attorney General
office is under the executive and that's
where you have all the State Law
Officers and the
prosecutors yes thank you ah from yes
please in the civil law tradition uh the
prosecution office is uh is an
independent body and is attached to the
Judiciary so uh our prosecution office
is organized like the Judiciary they
have a high uh High Council of uh for
prosecutors which is organized like the
high judicial Council and they have uh
the same Independence as the judges we
are regulated uh within the same bill
which called the law on the status of
judges and prosecutors so we have uh the
the same Arrangements uh judges and
prosecution and we attend the same uh
the same formation the same school all
of us have to
uh to have a low degree and then to uh
follow the formation uh in the school of
magistrates great thank you so you other
qu what I'm sorry yes go ahead please U
ju just a quick question uh our friend
from Albania a few minutes ago said that
they're losing some of their students to
immigration and my question is are you
concerned about your
long-term losses of these students that
you might be losing some of the best
Minds in the country and how it's going
to affect government uh science
technology and and business in the
future yeah uh I think it's it's a big
problem not only for Albania but for the
whole balans and uh I'm not sure what's
what our government is uh is doing to to
improve uh this
situation uh it has our prime minister
has been just Justified that uh it's an
World movement some goost some others
come in our country so it's a normal
process I I don't have any any stri
straight Ahad answer for that question
I'm sorry thank you so other uh other
questions for from from our guests
please please
yes hi uh so uh we uh visited several
Institution when we after we came here
so one of the institutions we visited is
public defenders office so in public
defenders office we heard that uh the
death penalty is abolished in the state
yes yeah and we heard that but still
there is one person who's in the death
row yes so uh then we heard that uh it
is the law is not
retrospective
and right that's that that's true there
is one person who has been who was
convicted and sentenced to death before
the law changed and the law that changed
you know that that abolished the death
penalty specifically says it is not it
applies prospectively only only for the
future not for the past yeah so I don't
know whether you will uh able to answer
this question yeah um so in my
perspective or if I think from a human
rights perspective then uh if the the
state is already taken a policy decision
to abolish it uh uh like the person
who's in the death row also maybe should
have that benefit of that because
already that policy decision is taken so
are there like any uh other uh
Alternatives that the commission
judicial commission or other ways yeah
so I I I I be if I'd be interested if
any of my colleagues comment I what I
would say is my understanding
is
that basically that's an I mean it's a
very interesting question uh there have
been C there are states around the
country where a somewhat where a similar
thing uh
happened uh you know a similar sort of
scenario and
I think Connecticut is the one that
comes to mind but I think there may be
others and in which the Supreme Court of
that state said well even though the
statute said it's only perspective you
can't apply it you can't execute someone
you know even if they were convicted
before
um I don't know if that I don't know if
there are if there are states that have
reached the opposite conclusion but it
it is is a you know it is an open
question I you there are there are
legitimate arguments on both sides of
that question I think and so my my
perspective and I'm not involved in this
at all anymore but my perspective is
that nobody wants to do anything every
you know in other words nobody's moving
the the the Attorney General's office is
not moving forward to try to execute the
person he remains in
jail um
and uh and you know there's
no at least as far as I know I and I
think there would probably be some
public you know something would be in
the newspaper if something nothing
really is happening it's just
everybody's kind of saying you know
let's just let's just leave this alone
that that's my perspective and I'd be
interested if anybody has any other
perspective I think um I think I agree
with um what I know I agree with what
the chair says um the person we're
talking about was
convicted um of um killing a police
officer and um
emotions run very
high I believe that
if the the
bill that eliminated n Hampshire's death
penalty was not prospective in other
words was not limited in that way it
would not have
passed uh and I think the dis for those
of us who had the opportunity to vote on
that I think the fact that it was
prospective made it possible for the
legislation to pass and it was important
to many of us that it
passed so in this as in virtually
everything the world is not perfect I
hope that doesn't surprise you you might
think the world is perfect but it's
not and so that was the price that was
paid that it would not be retrospective
that it would not not include this one
person if I had to
guess I would think the most likely
thing will H that would happen is
nothing the second most likely thing way
down the
list is that he would stay where he is
until he dies a natural death
I think the third
option of making this retrospective is
highly
unlikely um and so we have a
situation
where one could
say that one person is being
Deni protection under the
law and
that's and that's the way it is um this
is not a time to
discuss I don't think you
know whether he should be executed or
not executed we're talking here just
about the situation of the law but
you're absolutely right that it is
um it's not a
clear
situation one of the related issues that
I'd be curious about what happens in
your
country um has to do with
transparency and accountability on the
part of the government so that the
citizens of the
country might have an idea of what the
government's
doing but we also have laws which
protect um uh police
officers from
um potential
punishments or trials and punishments
that nonp police officers would be
subjected to um they have an additional
protection than other citizens have is
any of that does any of that sound
familiar in terms of how things work in
your country
it's
interesting so other other questions
please well if I'm sorry do somebody
have a question or all right represent
of CH then
please yeah thanks um I just sort of an
observation maybe more than a question
um and it's related to sort of like what
I see as the sort of uniqueness of this
committee
um it's a Judiciary Committee so it
obviously relates to you know our court
systems and and such um but a lot of the
issues and the bills that come come
before us are things that relate to what
I would call rights sort of the basic
you know human rights um bodily autonomy
you know questions of birth questions of
death questions of you know a lot of the
bills that we get are a lot less
concrete I would say than maybe some of
the other committees in the house
because there are sort of focused on
these sort of more um I hate to use the
word nebulous but maybe you know
Concepts that are harder to Define um
and there's a lot of back and forth I
think about what the role of the
government and legislature is in these
whether it's the role of the government
to Grant and establish these rights or
the role of the government to um
restrict or in some way control these
rights um so
it kind of goes back to your first
question which is what are the most
contentious issues and it it in my mind
it's sort of the most contentious issues
maybe should be the ones that come here
I will say you know and you may have
picked this up that we've managed to
work through those in in a very
collaborative collegial way most of the
bills that come out of here we we agree
on um but um I don't know if there's
time left but any any thoughts about
sort of the way that your governments
interact with sort of the these
questions of of um you know under
underlying rights I guess would people
thought usual Eric you asked a question
that just stopped us
all um but on the other side of that I
would add there other issues that are
very grounded that we're involved with
here for example landlord tenant
issues um the rights of landlords and
the rights of tenants and where is the
line between the two and if any of your
countries have figured out where that
line is do let us know because we
haven't figured it out
yet the other issue that um uh you rais
it you raised the question of
contentious issues the other issue that
we've we've dealt with um and it's it's
sort of beyond for this term anyway it's
it's in the past is the issue of
abortion um we had you know we had a
number of abortion bills and we had uh
um we we had uh debate and discussion
about those we we didn't all agree on on
uh on on all of them but we agreed on
some of them and uh that and those went
to the floor and there was a you know a
debate a heavy debate on the floor
regarding those bills and uh but that's
a uh that's uh you know that was that
was a contentious issue and I'm just
wondering is that you know is that an
issue in any of your countries it's uh
of that's you know subject to uh dis
dispute or anything like that
yes in The Gambia we have a draft
Constitution that is still pending in
the the house
because uh we we drafted the law in 2017
18 to 19 so in 2020 it was introduced in
the National Assembly and it was
rejected because um the opposition party
were of the view that the so the
president started his time before the
law was
introduced so and then in the draft
Constitution they were introducing term
limits before in our current
Constitution there are no time limits so
the draft
Constitution has two terms for the
president so the contentious issue was
the president was serving his first ter
and even if the Constitution is passed
he would have only one term so that
would be like two terms so the president
and uh his party said no we're not going
to do it so when the Constitution got to
the National
Assembly it was the con contentious
issues and that was one of because the
president's Party formed the majority in
the house
so that was the reason why the that was
the only reason why the Constitution was
not passed I it's still pending all
right
yes a gentleman just walked in and if he
would stand up um I would like you to
see that he pass on his jacket an orange
badge do you all know what that is
that badge shows that he is a lobbyist
he is here um to watch what we do and to
having tried to influence us to support
um his client's views and as you walk
through the State House complex in these
next few hours you will see people with
orange Badges and they're really lovely
people you don't have to avoid them them
you know they're not
contagious um you might agree with them
you might not but in this house because
we don't have we have very few staff
people we frequently depend upon
lobbyists to help give us background
information or help outline what the
issues are and the good lobbyists are
the ones who will tell us both sides of
the issue and you learn very soon who
are the good lobbyist who you can trust
who's going to tell you the truth as
against those who spin who just tell you
theirs but they are a very important
part of the legislative process here and
so I wanted to introduce you to a real
live off all right so representative
Perez you had a you had a representative
Perez representative Perez did you did
you have something I and I'm GNA kind of
wrap it up because I don't oh all right
I'm sorry do you have one one comment
and then I'm GNA wrap it up okay yeah I
I was going to say this to the committee
anyways um after we were done but I'm
going to say it now um I'm subbing for
actually in this committee I sub I'm
subbing this week for cam Kenny I sub
for um representative Paige over there
last week um so we're voting on some
bills today and I was able to see this
as well last week and one thing that I
saw about this committee was that was
really agreeable and that we were able
to get done or I watched them be able to
get done at least
um was like with the AI bill with in
regards to artificial
intelligence um so to leave you guys
with something good you know we were
able to with the committee and also
along with spreading across um three
other committees that had AI bills we
realized there was not a an official
definition in the law for that and um so
that has been worked on and we are like
voting on that today so um it was that's
something that I watched um within a
week that was able to get accomplished
so I really appreciate um being able to
witness and be a part of it and thank
you for taking me in I met welome thank
you for being here so um I know that you
probably have other places you you you
need to be um uh and so I want to thank
you all and I'm G to I'm going to um
recess this schedule for a minute before
I start the executive session so that we
can you know we can kind of come up and
shake hands with you you and just maybe
have a few minutes of of personal
conversation and then we'll uh turn to
the executive uh session all right again
thank you so much for
coming I'm so no that absolutely I okay
no that's that's that's fine I thought I
thought you had somewhere else to go but
that's great we'd love to have
you oh all right all right well then
maybe the
that' be great sure group photo yeah
absolutely let's do
that much more pleasant
discussion
e
uh ladies and gentlemen uh we don't we
don't have a long agenda but we do have
an
agenda
want the Gap oh no no I don't got do
that you know what we really I do think
that this committee kind of sets the uh
the example on deating the idea not
indiv
I can't think of any kind
of
AR
e
all right so um I'd like to uh call uh
the executive session of the Judiciary
Committee to order and I'd ask you
please uh first to join me in the Pledge
of Allegiance
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
Justice all right
um so I guess uh I call the uh executive
session to order and the first bill that
I would like to turn to is House Bill
1082 um and I guess I would uh recognize
representative tur to uh uh to speak to
that uh yeah thank thank you um chair uh
so I I distributed the um the amendment
to the bill uh both by email and sorry
sorry it's it's a Amendment
1060 yeah um and this is this is
actually a combination of two amendments
um one that came from our original
hearing um which is sort of the
modifications of the the the upper
portion of the bill which really was
just restructuring a sentence from the
original bill to make it clearer uh
which uh entities within the
organization uh did or did not have to
be qualified um people within the
profession um and then the the low the
latter part of it is sort of why we
formed the subcommittee for this bill
which was questions around the
interactions
between
the the corporate entity that this uh
affects and the profession that the
corporate entity exists within um
basically needing to clarify two things
one is that the person serving in this
assistant manager role because they're
not a a qualified
individual uh that they cannot exercise
any professional judgment or render any
Professional Services while they're
serving in that capacity um and then and
then the other um piece of it was to
clarify because this came up with um uh
some some guidance that that
representative Manos uh brought for us
from the bar association I believe which
basically speaks about what a single
member legal practice uh should do when
the member dies or becomes
incapacitated um and when we looked at
them they weren't inherently in conflict
with each other um but they it certainly
was worth clarifying that what we're
trying to do here wouldn't override the
guidance of the profession in terms of
what they do because the the legal
profession because because they're uh
they they're governed by the Supreme
Court they have to basically appear um
you know before a judge to do some of
the things that were trying to say the
the at least the clinical professions is
where I got a lot of insights from don't
don't have to do um I will say we
uh I I spoke just before this and I
hadn't had a chance even to talk to
representative Ming following our our uh
our our subcommittee meeting but I did
get in touch with the ass uh assistant
Secretary of State this morning um she
basically said they haven't had a time
to look at this in depth um they don't
see any problems with it on the surface
um they said basically it may be um some
issues around modifying reporting forms
for corporations that are or plc's that
are in this situation going forward so
it's clear sort of how they're operating
um so basically they said they they
won't be able to really complete that
until the end of the week but they said
you know it's okay from their
perspective to to go forward um there's
no red flags at the moment and then you
know if anything comes up it it may
require us to you know look at an
amendment uh on the floor or an
amendment through senate or something so
um the the clinical professions didn't
raise any issues we talked to the um
talked to the medical society they
checked with um oplc licensing um
Authority for across everyone and they
didn't raise any any issues so so that's
what the amendment does um sorry I
should have said my my I don't know if
I'm supposed to start within a a motion
well you probably you probably should
probably should have started with that's
all right so my so so my motion would be
ought to pass and I'm introducing
Amendment uh
1060 um in in regards to what I just
spoke about all right and is there a
second rep represent
Manis
okay well you know before we do that is
there a second to the
motion I'll second the motion thank you
all right so Mo motion's been moved and
seconded um and representative Mana
thank you Mr chair um I as an attorney I
do have concerns about the ethical
implications of the
amendment um I did reach out to the bar
association I did ask that they provide
guidance from the Ethics Committee
because of the shortness of time
involved they weren't able to do that I
believe representative Ming also was
interested in hearing from an attorney
who practices in the area of business
entity formation but I my view at this
point is that we should pass the
amendment um have it go to the floor and
there would be time in the Senate
assuming the house passes it there would
be time in the Senate to hear from the
Ethics Committee of the bar association
and an attorney who practices business
entity law and um if there are problems
at that point we can amend the bill
again other anyone else wish to be heard
uh representative Ming and then
representative
Oregon yeah I just want uh thank you Mr
chair um I just wanted to say that I I I
do second what representative Mano said
um about my concerns initially for this
bill I think it's
um I think it's a good sign that the
Secretary of State's office gave a kind
of cursory um thumbs up um so thank you
representative tur for doing that uh for
looking into it so um I I'm in agreement
with um representative Manos um I think
we should pass this amendment and um
pass the Bill great thank you
representative Oregon um I mean I think
the language here is sufficient for this
situation by warning about the situation
where the assistant man manager is not a
qualified person but they're in the
process of trying to become one let's
say I'll pick on him probably isn't fair
to pick on him because he's not here
today but let's say rep let's say I was
a lawyer which thankfully I am not a
lawyer but if I was what if I had a law
practice and I had uh representative
Kenny here as my assistant manager and
he was doing that while also studying
for his bar exam which hopefully he'll
be passing uh later this year so like
what if so if you have a situation like
that where the assistant man manager
isn't qualified at the time that the
vacancy occurs but then becomes one
during that year
so all right
um representative tur well I'm sorry
representative tur and then
representative Perez yeah at my
understanding or I think the intent at
least of of the bill is that um you know
if that person was appointed as the
assistant manager they could basically
operate the business you know uh it
doesn't require that they not be a
member of the profession just says they
don't have to be one so essentially they
my understanding would be they could
serve in that capacity and then you know
um I I I don't know what the process
would be to sort of become the the
actual manager going forward but I don't
think anything would be precluded by it
unless someone has a different
opinion repres representative Perez
I have two questions um becoming a
disqualified person does that mean if
you fire them that would fall under this
no so disqualified and qualified is sort
of the language about whether or not
you're you're uh qualified under the the
professional lure so it would be like
being disbarred or being you know having
your license revoked or suspended that
kind of thing
followup yes
so if someone's terminated for any
reason this doesn't cover
it remember I was a nurse not a lawyer
so terminated as an employee of the
practice so as a manager I mean could so
so they they're the directors of the
corporation so my second question is why
would we want I don't understand quite
the rationale between for passing this
and then amending it in the sent Senate
I don't think I've heard us doing that I
mean I'm not saying it isn't done but I
don't think I've heard us doing that in
my short time here doing
that well I guess I would say to that I
mean I I think you're right in the sense
that we you know we we it we don't
generally do that but I but but it's not
I I've I've heard a number of times in
connection with legislation both in this
committee and and in other committees
that you know if there's some sort of
minor issue it'll you know we'll it'll
it'll the Senate will fix it or whatever
and so you know don't hold up the
legislation but I have to say me and I
very I appreciate representative Manis
and representative
Ming's um concerns but you know as I
look at this I really think that the
language here is I'm going to be very
surprised if there's any if there's any
concerns because it says very clearly in
this in the in this amendment the
non-quality ified person can't do
anything that requires qualification so
the you know the I think in
representative Oregan to use your
example I think if representative Kenny
were to think oh you know I'm I'm taking
the bar exam tomorrow and I really know
all the law and it's okay for me to sort
of counil you know some uh some uh
client of the of the now deceased
lawyers firm uh representative Kenny is
going to have some real
problems um so I think you know my sense
is that this does address the the issue
pretty clearly I mean it's you know and
it says it really sort of more than once
um if if you're not if you're not a
licensed lawyer you can't do anything
that amounts to practicing law if you're
not a licensed doctor you can't do
anything that amounts to practicing
medicine then so I'm I'm you know I I am
satisfied that the language is good
um uh yes representative D Lorenzo thank
you Mr chair um I just need to um air my
feelings about this and I am I don't
know if I'm totally comfortable um with
moving forward with this bill when there
are issues that aren't that haven't been
settled um one is the ethics issue um by
the barer Association that um
representative mayos uh mentioned and
then the other one is um the SOS giving
sort of like thumbs up on the Bell so
that's just my opinion um I'd like to
see all the loops all the loops closed
but um that wouldn't prevent me from
voting going forward thank any other
comments representative
me thank you Mr chair uh just one
further um comment uh I brought this up
in the subcommittee hearing and um I
just wanted to say that this is not just
um an eth
it wasn't just an ethical concern for me
it was the fact that these there are
business entity options and a lot of
them uh in the state of New Hampshire
and they can range from small
corporations big corporations
Partnerships all of all different types
llc's um limited liability Partnerships
um so to kind of upend what has
traditionally been done for PL
I without hearing from an expert that's
that's what my main concern was that we
are changing something that is not
captured in this bill in this amendment
and we're changing something about the
law that we we are unsure of um but I am
relying on the Secretary of State's
office knowing their stuff about this
and um and I will still support the Bill
thank you all right any other comments
representative Andrew I'm sorry thank
you Mr chair do we have to exact this
bill today or can we wait for our
answers I think we have don't we have to
when crossover is when
uh
um yeah
second it's not crossover it's when is
the last right the last day right for
March 20 last day to report house bills
not in the second committee is March
21st right so I really think this is
this is it yeah that's what that was my
concern is that we really um and you
know can I just can I just follow
represent I guess the thing I'm not I
mean other than
the other than the implications
of someone professional
practicing that they're not you know
when they're not licensed to practice
which I think this addresses I'm not I'm
not sure I'm following the other in
other words what what are the other
things that you see would be a problem
that's I'm having trouble understanding
what those would be uh thank you for the
question um I I think this is a case of
we we kind of don't know what we don't
know um and I I don't
think the pl was created for just for
fun you know it was it was created for a
reason and I'm not sure what that reason
is and I we we haven't exactly heard a
professional say what that reason is um
because there are llc's and there are
plc's and in some states you can there
there are professionals that are
licensed that are not permitted to form
llc's and I don't know if that is the
case in New Hampshire and I I don't
practice business entity law in New
Hampshire so I don't know the answer to
that question um and that that that is
my main concern okay I you know I mean I
guess what I it it would seem to me I I
and I don't profess to be an expert in
this area either but it would seem to me
that the that the reason we
have uh P
LLC differences from regular LLC is that
there's a there's with PC's you want
to ensure that the that the uh a member
of the of the pllc is is professionally
licensed um I I think that I mean that
you know I I don't think that there's
another reason beyond that and so if you
if
you merely allow an assistant manager
who's not licensed to do nonprofessional
things for what is it up to a year right
that's up to a year I guess I don't see
how that could you know sort of upset
the the pllc world I would and and I
guess you know law lawyers have been the
the the area that has um was raised by
representative Manos but as I understand
from representative tur the medical
society has
been uh questioned about this and
perhaps you've talked with other
professional professionals that don't
seem to have a problem so I that you
know that sort of gives me a lot of
comfort representative
Smith thank you very much
um I find this uh conversation
fascinating because basically everything
that we do that involves A
Change Is involving a change and um so
uh if we didn't ever do that we wouldn't
have to spend any time here at all we
could be out enjoying the sun um I
listened uh I think carefully to what my
colleague said about the uh the variety
of professional limited liability
companies out there but we're talking
here about a
single member
professional limited liability we're not
talking about
um General Foods we're not talking about
any large Enterprise where of course
we're not relying on one person we're
talking about a tiny not even a mom and
pop operation a tiny mom operation or
pop operation but not both and this is
dealing with the
situation that I think shows great
responsibility on the part of the
individual who brought this bill to
representative tur's attention and that
is he is a member of a professional
limited liability company he knows he's
not going to live forever or be able to
function forever and he wanted to make
sure that everyone was
able to carry out what needed to be
carried out when he was no longer the
professional that's all this is it is
not remaking corporate law it is not
addressing any major entity it's just
seeing in this very limited case where
there is a single member professional
who has set up a limited liability
company
this is to deal with what happens when
that person for whatever reason is no
longer able to function so it's not a
question of a manager being fired it's
not a question of of any of those things
it's just um uh it's it's like
uh like a medical power of Eternity is
you know the same kind of thing making
sure that there's somebody who can bring
this to an end without ignoring the
responsibility to the clients or the
patrons or whatever word you want to use
so I mean I don't want to say it's no
big deal because anything is a big deal
but I I think we're overthinking this a
little bit can I can I just make one
last yes representative CH please um and
I want to sort of it's a little bit
addressing representative Perez's
question um as far as I know and please
others that particularly on our
subcommittee no one's sort of bubbled up
known problem with this that that we
haven't like addressed it the question I
think the reason that the Secretary of
State's office and and perhaps others is
that there are folks that um we haven't
fully heard from you know people were
invited to our subcommittee meeting but
we we didn't we didn't have that input
directly so you know I I I it's not like
we're passing a bill but we know their
flaws and we're hoping someone will fix
them down the line I guess you know as
far as I know and please everyone
correct me is is we we've dealt with it
we've added language to make it as clear
as possible the delineation between sort
of what's corporate and what's
professional um in in the bill so I I I
just wanted to make it clear and and the
other thing a little bit to
representative Ming's statement from our
our our subcommittee um there are other
corporate entities besides plc's and and
in the subcommittee I think I one of my
points was these exist they are single
entity uh plc's in the state and whether
or not that was their best possible
choice you know 30 years ago when it was
formed versus versus you know versus
today is is an area I'm hoping to sort
of avoid because the very existence of
them I think is is the basis for for why
we're considering making the change all
right any uh representative trip um
correct me if I'm wrong but it seems
that the entire purpose for this bill is
to permit a clean shutdown of a company
you know uh and as uh representative
Smith said you
know that needs this needs to be done so
the I guess the question I would have is
what if we
don't pass this bill what what kind of
situation would uh
be required when the sole professional
in an LLC you know
is the dies or whatever you know what
what happens in that
situation no I mean I I let
representative tur speak to that but I
think that's exactly the point I think
you rais exactly the point of of this
yeah and I I think the distinction from
your question is a good one which is you
know because of the unique Str structure
and because of this prohibition on
naming somebody other than the the sole
you know professional it sort of leaves
these organizations in a what we've
described as a catch 22 they they can't
make a proactive decision sort of the
way it works is you sort of have a an
Unwritten agreement with another
professional to sort of come in and and
help you close out your business and
what it leaves you with is essentially
this business that that has has been
your profession has no way forward it
basically has to shut down whereas with
this individual able to make
decisions that person could help um
could bring someone on on a contractual
basis to serve U not not you know not
not as a a member but as to to provide
Professional Services they could sell
the business to another entity they
could convert it to another type of
legal entity like an LLC that that
doesn't have that requirement so it
gives them a whole range of ways forward
other than just essentially seeing the
business essentially collapse and go
into into
probate
thank you Mr chair I just wanted to um
respond to representative Trip's
question by saying that I think the
situation with a single
member uh law practice pllc is different
than rep representative tur just
described so the B Association has both
ethical and um succession planning
guidance for single member um
plc's and there's a whole ethical
standard for what what is to occur when
the single member
pllc attorney dies or is disqualified or
becomes
disabled and that's where I think some
of the tension is coming from and it's
why we added the final two
sentences um but I would just repeat
that I think once this bill goes to the
other body assuming it makes it there if
it goes to the other body then that body
will hear testimony which could include
um someone from the bar association and
could include an attorney who does
business entity formation practice and
so I think we'll get I think that the
other body will get the answers to those
questions well can I just interrupt to
just and apologize to we I just asked
Karen to pass around a a document for
the next bill we're going to take up and
I copied the wrong document so ignore
what you ignore what was just passed
around to you we're getting the right
document uh uh to you when we get to
1432 and I
apologize that's the one I I emailed
last night yes I'm I'm sorry so anyway
back to uh back to 1082 does anyone have
any further um comments on on the
amendment uh therefore well then I'm
going to uh I'm going to uh ask I think
we can uh vote on the amendment by ra
show of hands does anybody object to
that all right then all all those in
favor of adopting Amendment 2024
1060 to House Bill 1082 please raise
your
hand appears that we are unanimous
anyone opposed right so 20
to0
um all right
and since that replaces the the
amendment places the uh replaces the
entire
uh bill I guess except for the um the
effective date right that's the only
thing that's the only thing that's left
is that right representative
tur yeah yeah it's all right all right
so then I guess we're we're now on to
the main motion of
otpa um anyone have anything further to
say all right then I would ask the clerk
to please call the role uh the motion
being otpa on House Bill
1082 and that motion was made by repur
and seconded by chairman Lynn because we
didn't oh yes we only made the first
motion and second so you make a you make
a you make a motion to
otpa and I'll
second thank you Vice chairman Wallace
yes rep Alexander
no rep Andrews yes rep testerman
no
rette
no rep trip
yes rep nder
yes clerk aab votes yes rep Perez
no rep Smith yes rep Horan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep cybert yes rep pagee yes
rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
repur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
yes motion passes 16
to4 all right
um representative tur I can I ask you to
write the report will there be a
Minority Report
all
right all right um then we
are wait that am oh that's right yes
yeah we're going to take a just a brief
recess until I until we get the uh and
last let me let me just ask you this I
did send it out by email last night does
everybody everybody have the email or I
mean I'm happy to you don't all right no
then we'll get I'll wait until we get so
let's take a brief recess until we get
the uh the
amendment
e
all right um can we uh can we uh
reconvene
yeah
some regarding the last bill will will
there be a Minority
Report uh no it will
not all
right all
right so um I'd now like to open the
hearing on uh the executive session
rather on House Bill
1432 and um I'm going to recognize
myself uh to
move Amendment uh
1100h and is there a second I
second somebody else oh second second by
representative Manos all right um
to give me one second
uh all right all right and
um I'd like to uh speak to the motion so
this um first I want to say um as you
may recall this was representative gon's
uh bill
initially um and it's um it's now had uh
it's now been touched so to speak by a
number of representatives and I
particularly want to thank
representative uh Manos and
representative
Corman um we we we
uh relied heavily on representative
corman's expertise in the definition
sections of what artificial intelligence
what constitutes artificial intelligence
and what constitutes a deep fake and
candidly his his definitions were much
better than our original definitions um
um and so I really appreciate his work
on that um as you may know there were I
believe
five bills in various committees dealing
with um one aspect or another of
artificial intelligence um the the
criminal uh Justice and Public Safety
commission committee had two
bills um uh both of which they have uh
one of which I I believe they already uh
we already voted on um uh to to itl it
and the other one I think is is up uh
they're not going forward with it with
it anyway and as a result of this
meeting I was uh that I should spend
some time on talking to you about so
there was there was two bills in
criminal justice there's one in
Edna and there's won an election and
then there's
1432 we had a meeting um earlier this
week um the main goal of which was to
make sure that in all of those bills we
use the same Definition of artificial
intelligence and now we've we we have we
achieved agreement at that meeting that
that that the definition of artificial
intelligence and deep fake uh that is in
uh in this bill will be the same
definition that is used in um all the
other bills um criminal justice is not
going to go forward with their bills
because this bill has a criminal penalty
um uh criminal violation provision in it
now the speaker may just so you know the
speaker may decide if we uh if this bill
is passed on the floor he may decide to
refer this bill to criminal justice for
some further review because it does
include a criminal penalty
provision ah VI okay so presumably he
will not do that then okay because
because of the deadline all right but
anyway they know I mean criminal justice
knows that we're going forward with this
and they're fine they're they're they're
fine with that they basically defer to
us
um uh with regard to election
law they are going they are very
concerned uh on bipartisan basis in
election law with having a bill that
will take effect as soon as possible
because they're concerned about the
upcoming election they their bill
dealing with this the only remedy that
it will have is a the ability to get an
injunction in other words there's not
going to be any criminal
penalty um uh and there is some language
apparently in their bill that says you
know May pursue other uh other available
remedies so supposedly I mean presumably
somebody might be able to bring some
kind of civil
lawsuit um but the main thing they're
concerned about is the ability to get an
injunction they will not have any
criminal penalties in their bill
um
nonetheless as as I pointed out to them
when this bill becomes effective which
will not be in time for this election
but when this bill becomes effective
there will the criminal penalties that
apply here or the Civil penalties civil
remedies that apply presumably could
apply you know not to to deep fakes in
the election context or in any other
context so it could apply um uh to
election um issues um so the
the next thing that I want to uh kind of
review with everyone is um it you'll see
that in section one of the bill a crime
is defined uh class B felony if somebody
uses a deep
fake uh for purposes of embarrassing
harassing and trapping defaming
extorting or otherwise causing any
Financial or reputational harm to an
identifiable person and then there's a
separate class B felony if as a result
of the deep fake um someone
um uh someone is is uh you know
improperly arrested
um um that's a that's a separate felony
the important things to note here and
this applies to both the criminal
penalties and the Civil cause of action
that is created are the are the four
exceptions uh which in which state
basically when the the prohibitions of
the statute don't
apply
um three of them
are controlled to a greater or lesser
extent by federal law the first one is
um section
230 of uh title 47 of the US
code um which uh which uh
basically precludes us from um imposing
liability um on on someone who is just a
um an interactive Computer Service uh uh
a computer service provider as defined
in the statute but note that there's an
exception the the
the the immunity for lack of a better
term that is that federal law affords to
um internet computer service providers
is if they're acting just as an
internet uh service provider you'll note
that this that if the if the Deep fake
was actually created by the internet
service provider then they're acting in
another role and they could be held by
they're not they're not excluded then um
the second uh Sub sub paragraph
B um is designed
to indicate that we're not either
criminalizing or provide or affording as
a basis for civil remedy situations in
which a the media is reporting about a
deep fake in other words if they're if
you know if they're going to if they're
running a story that says candidate a uh
ran a deep fake about candidate B and
that's the story um then they're then
they're entitled I mean I think it
probably would be a First Amendment
violation if you if they couldn't do
that but this allows them to do that um
it indicates though that that there must
be a clear
acknowledgment in the in the story that
there's a question about the
authenticity of the materials I mean
they can't um they if they're going to
run a story about um a deep fake they H
they have to knowledge that there's at
least a question about it C is the one
that representative Manos and I had a
number of discussions about because it's
candidly it's a it's something that I
think both of us feel it's too bad
federal law is the way it is but it
essentially what it says is that in
regard to paid political
advertising
um there that's exempt from the criminal
and civil penalties that are
created um provided that the entity that
the entity the magazine newspaper
television station whatever um does not
remove or modify any disclaimer provided
by the Creator or sponsor of the
election communication so what this
means and I'm you know I I went back and
forth with some of the people from the
communications industry about this
because I was really I was basically
saying to them show me because I what I
wanted to say was I originally as this
was drafted it would have
said if you know if you're a if you're a
broadcaster that's dealing with a paid
political advertisement and you know not
just think or maybe you should know
whatever but you know it's a deep
fake and you go ahead and run it anyway
you should be held liable they said no
no you can't do that that's violation of
federal law and I said show me and they
did they they showed they basically it's
this is goes back to I think this the
communications Act of 1934 I think and
it's not
worded you know in the way that we would
like a modern statute might be word but
it basically what it says is no
censorship um and that has been
interpreted to me and I and I
suppose mean I I I I suppose you can
make an argument of understanding why
this is so and in the political context
I guess the idea is you know All is fair
and Love and War and if it's politics
you know that's that's kind of the way
that's uh we don't want to be we don't
want to be sort
of really
uh carefully carefully scrutinizing what
people say in political campaigns
because that'll show First Amendment
rights and all that at any rate um
that's that's the way the the law has
been interpreted is that you know they
if it's even if it's
false if it's a paid political
advertisement they have to run it and
note that the disclaimer that is at that
referred to in the end of the of section
c that disclaimer does not mean does not
mean that that the disclaimer says by
the way this is a deep fate it just
means that you know the standard thing
this is a paid political advertisement
if they put that in there um you know I
I guess the theory is you're on notice
that this a paid political advertisement
and you know those politicians they may
say anything so so be on your guard I
think that's the idea and then the last
one uh the LA subsection
D is that um there's an exception where
uh you're talking about a parody or
satire if somebody
if somebody's uh uh doing a deep fake
that
um it involves some kind of parody or
satire I again I think there would be a
First Amendment problem if you tried to
uh prohibit that so um that's uh the
language as I should say it has
been reviewed by representative Corman
who drafted the definitions by
representative Manos and by this other
group group of bipartisan group of the
other
committees um and although they were I
wanted in in in fairness they were
focusing mainly on the definitions but
they did review the the the language and
I haven't and we've we've accommodated
the qu the suggestions and changes made
by representative Manos and
representative Corman um and I think I
think this is good to go so with that
I'll shut up and uh take questions
representative tur yeah just one
question on that section c that you just
talked about it we sort you sort of
described it as pertaining to paid
political ads but it's not really worded
that way it's sort of worded just to
apply to any paid um publication if I'm
reading it right and so I wasn't sure I
know it says disclaimer at the end but
um that's only if they don't remove a
disclaimer so I didn't know is part C
basically meant to cover all um all paid
publication no I think what it says
it is paid to publish distributor
broadcast an election
communication ah okay an election
communication okay sorry I was looking
for political but I found the wrong word
okay thank you other
questions yes representative
Oregon these a little bit tricky just
because things have gotten so bizarre in
recent years it's hard to tell what's
attire what's real these days but I I
mean I think the language that we have
in here is is fine so it does allow
people to continue to saiz or parody the
political process even though as I said
it's hard to tell these days what's a
parody and what's real but that's and
you know I think I I think you're
absolutely right I I would this is as
with with the
Privacy bill that we dealt with uh a
while ago which is now by the way become
law 255 is now law um
uh this is something that that should be
dealt with I think on the at the federal
level uh you know for for uniformity and
I really do think that Congress should
at least consider changing the the
section I referred to before because wow
if you really know that something is
just BL you know the thing that came to
my mind is suppose the day before the
election uh uh candidate Biden on the
one hand or candidate Trump on the other
got somebody to uh you
know fake that person's campaign uh
management saying you know I uh I'm
sorry to report that the candidate
passed away this afternoon I mean and it
was absolutely false if a broadcaster
knew that and broadcasted it anyway I
would you
know they walk away from that I would
say I would have a problem with that but
that seems to be I don't think
fortunately a case like that hasn't come
up but I mean it does seem like that's
that's something that Congress ought to
deal with um anyway uh further
comments All right so um I guess then on
the amendment um I think can we do that
by a show of hands um uh all those in
favor of amendment 2024 1100 please
raise your hand
hand all right
unanimous all right
um hang on
that all right and then um on the main
uh on the main motion I would uh
move uh otpa is there a
second all our second by representative
man and um could I ask the anyone anyone
else have any comments want all right
then I would ask the clerk to please
call the role Vice chairman Wallace yes
rep
Alexander rep Andrews yes rep
testerman rep ulette yes
rep trip yes rep ner yes clerk tab votes
yes rep Perez yes rep Smith yes rep
Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep
cybert yes rep Paige yes rep Divine yes
rep lonza yes rep Manos yes rep tur yes
rep Ming yes chairman Lynn yes motion
passes 20 to0 uh consent all right
consent it's got
oh but it's not going to but it not it
was yeah it was not an early bill so I
let's try it for consent Paul will tell
me if we're wrong
okay right yeah he will definitely tell
you we're wrong and I will write the uh
report on that um all right I think
think we yes certainly uh I noticed that
there are two bills from the Senate that
were put on our
plates um and I looked at one of them
and I think it might be here in error
and before you do anything about
scheduling it I wonder if you would
check with um the powers that be because
I think it ought to go to um Health and
Human Services I I will do that no
that's that I will absolutely do that so
that leaves only
one Senate Bill do you have any idea of
how many other Senate bills we're going
to get have you been given a secret I no
I have not I think I think there are
more than these two but I don't but I
don't uh I don't know how many um so you
know what let me let me I guess what I I
I think you're you make a very good
suggestion and I will definitely do that
to check on that it includes the
judicial branch in the office of public
Guardian right that's the only reference
and no yeah so I will know I'm going to
go see Paul um you know right away and
ask him about whether that but let me
ask you this so here's so I guess what I
the way I'd like to leave it is this I'm
gonna and I'm GNA do this right away if
we
have by if 185 stays with Judiciary and
we have two bills that uh my inclination
would be to have an exec I mean to have
a hearing um next Wednesday starting at
10: if it's only one bill if 185 goes
away and it's only one bill um I
probably would would not but we it may
be that we have you know that I that we
have other bills that I don't know about
yet that that are there and
so yeah but meanwhile in order to get C
I have to do it Wednesday and you'd have
to know by noon i' have right right
exactly no exactly so I'm going to try
to find guess what I'm saying is um we
may or may not we may we may or may not
if there I would probably if it's just
one bill I won't do it if it's more than
one bill I probably will do it but we'll
start at 10 o'clock and uh yes
representative Bo um this one regardless
of whether we are
HHS does it um the
sooner sooner it gets through the
process assuming the P house uh agrees
to it um the sooner it gets to the
governor's Destiny assign it and the can
be appointed and start its
work um sooner so that would give it
like a couple more weeks if we did it
sooner that might make a difference if
it has like whatever however three or
four more weeks to do its work because
it's supposed to have everything done by
November 1st which uh seems like a long
way away but it's pretty soon so you
know what representative cab just
checked and apparently there are six
bills that have gone to us so chances
are we will be meeting next Wednesday um
I'm going to go
uh I'm going to go talk with Karen right
now but I think we probably will be
meeting on Wednesday um you know one
other thing that I wanted to um bring up
just so that I I've talked to
representative Smith about this um so
everybody knows this there you may
remember that we passed um Senate Bill
255 we made some changes um one of the
changes that we made was to have the
Secretary of State involved in the um
involved in the process of how of what
companies that are subject to it uh sort
of have to do um the secretary of state
has has now and that by the way that
bill as just as we passed it it was
passed by the house and the Senate
concurred and the governor signed it so
it's now the law um the secretary of
state has proposed some changes to the
bill that substantive that I at least
personally I I've looked at them I don't
have any problem with the substance of
what the Secretary of State wants to
changes to be
but the the the upshot of those changes
would be
that the secretary of state would be
sort of out of the business of having
any particular role in the in the
Privacy thing in other words it would it
would state in sort of in detail this is
what this is what what companies have to
do but the the the secretary of state
would be kind of out of it um and I rais
that just because I know that I think
sort of on a bipartisan basis um people
had some people wanted the Secretary of
State to be involved so um and I anyway
this is just this is just this is
something that I my point here is this
is something that may come back to us at
some point and just sort of have it on
your radar screen I guess it's all I
would say um if I could just add to that
you were kind enough to ask me about it
and to ask representative f um who was
um a sponsor and both representative F
and I um were not as positive as you are
about um supporting that change um so I
don't know how that will un fold CU I
don't know what the secretary of state
will do about it in the Senate but I
just thought that helps to complete the
story you know and so you know what just
just a sort of slight clarification what
I what I want to say is I in terms of
the substance of the
changes I I don't have any problem with
the substance of the changes but what I
what I do have at least an issue with I
guess I'm open on this is it would seem
to me that one of the possibilities
would be that the we that the Secretary
of State could simply adopt those
changes as
regulations uh which would kind of keep
him his office in the in the sort of
review role that I think the legislation
originally um contemplated
and you know the I mean I I sort of
understand why they don't want to do
that but um that's sort of what I think
we wanted them to do so yeah I have a I
think that this is a little bit like
putting the fox in charge of the hen
housee saying that the very
corporations
um that we think might benefit from a
little outside
review um would be reviewing themselves
in a way it reminds me of what we were
troubled with about the Department of
Environmental Services that the same
people who conduct the hearings would
conduct the
appeals um and rather than have a fresh
look at it um now there's no telling how
that will unfold but that's I think why
both representative Earth and I had a
little
problem right so anything else anybody
wants to uh discuss all right well great
thanks everybody and uh so we will you
can count that we'll be on for next week
okay
thanks